Hi, Sean. No, you're Scotty. Oh, hi, Scotty. How are you today? I was wondering if you would stick around and listen to Smartless. Welcome to Smartless. That was very good. Smartless. Smartless. Smartless. Good morning. Good morning, everybody. Hi. Hi. everybody. Hi. Hi.
嗨，肖恩。不，你是斯科蒂。哦，嗨，斯科蒂。你今天好吗？我在想你是否愿意留下来听听《Smartless》。欢迎来到《Smartless》。那非常好。Smartless。Smartless。Smartless。早上好。大家早上好。嗨。嗨。大家。嗨。嗨。
Hi. Great. Sean, you all packed? Sean, you all packed? I was just going to say I just finished packing. I hate packing. Wait, Sean, yes. You're going to England?
嗨。太棒了。肖恩，你都收拾好行李了吗？肖恩，你都收拾好行李了吗？我正想说我刚收拾完。我讨厌收拾行李。等等，肖恩，是的。你要去英国？
I'm going to England. Yes, the United Kingdom. Yes. What else? To work on a fantastic new project. Do you want to talk about it? No, I mean, it's a little fun cameo in a movie called The Running Man.
我要去英国。是的，联合王国。是的。还有什么？去参与一个很棒的新项目。你想谈谈它吗？不，我是说，这只是电影《奔跑者》里的一个小客串。
With our friend Edgar Wright is directing. Edgar Wright is directing. We should have him on the show, by the way. I know, we should. I've wanted to for a while, and he's a fan. He's a big fan of the show. I know, he loves it. We love him, too.
我们的朋友埃德加·赖特在执导。埃德加·赖特在执导。顺便说一句，我们应该请他上节目。我知道，我们应该。我一直想请他，而且他是我们的粉丝。他是这个节目的忠实粉丝。我知道，他很喜欢这个节目。我们也喜欢他。
Well, he's going to be busy for a little while now, right? Yeah, they've been shooting already for a while. For Tracy Edgar Wright directed Shaun of the Dead, Hot Fuzz, Baby Driver, tons of great movies. Yeah. Tons. Really good filmmaker.
嗯，他现在要忙一阵子了，对吧？是的，他们已经拍了一段时间了。特蕾西，埃德加·赖特执导了《僵尸肖恩》、《热血警探》、《极盗车神》，还有很多很棒的电影。是的。很多。非常优秀的电影制作人。
Yeah. He's a very good filmmaker. And a good guy. And a good guy. Yeah, but I packed my sanitizer because I'm like Jason a little bit where I have the sanitizer wiped, so I wipe down the seats before I sit down
是的。他是一位非常优秀的电影制作人。也是个好人。也是个好人。是的，但我带了消毒液，因为我有点像杰森，我有消毒湿巾，所以我坐下之前会把座位擦一遍。
and I wipe down all of them. Do you really? Yeah, absolutely. See, I would be- Don't you pass, Jason. Yeah, like what are you talking about? I would feel embarrassed that I'm making such a big, like do you try to sneak that at all?
我把它们都擦了一遍。你真的这么做吗？是的，绝对。你看，我会——别通过，杰森。是的，你在说什么？我会觉得尴尬，因为我做得这么大张旗鼓，你有没有试着偷偷做？
I don't put music- Now you're embarrassed? I am. What, this is the line? I don't put music on with arrows pointing at me. Like, look as I, you know, I do it like, you know, quietly. But so you, what about theater seats when you're at a movie theater?
我没有放音乐——现在你觉得尴尬了？我是。什么，这是台词吗？我没有放着箭头指向我的音乐。就像，看我，你知道，我做得，你知道，很安静。但是，你在电影院的时候，电影院的座位呢？
Do you do that as well? Or do you, I wear a hoodie like this when I want it. No, I do, I do, but I do bring sanitizer to a movie theater. And for the arm rests? For the, yeah, but I don't wipe the seats and I just make sure I don't touch them a lot. You guys, you guys are what's wrong with this country. But here's the thing.
你也那样做吗？还是你，我想要的时候会穿像这样的连帽衫。不，我会，我会，但我确实会带消毒液去电影院。那扶手呢？对于，是的，但我不会擦座位，我只是确保我不怎么碰它们。你们，你们就是这个国家的问题所在。但问题是。
Truly, truly, I truly mean that. I do, sincerely, and I love you both. Oh, that's the problem in this country. But Will, don't you, see, because my brain goes immediately too, so the back rests of theater seats or plane seats, you lean against it and then you go right to your pillow, right? So you lean back on your pillow at home in your bed
真的，真的，我是真心的。我确实，真诚地，而且我爱你们俩。哦，这就是这个国家的问题。但是威尔，你不觉得吗，因为我的大脑立刻就会想到，剧院座位或飞机座位的靠背，你靠在上面，然后你就直接靠在你的枕头上了，对吧？所以你回到家躺在床上靠在枕头上。
and then eventually you flip over onto your side or your face and your mouth's open and you're just like. So there's a direct connection. But what are you talking about? I don't go from the, I don't go from seeing a movie to laying down. Well, you do eventually at the end of the night, you go home from the theater, you put on your little PJs and then you climb into bed.
然后你最终翻身侧卧或脸朝下，嘴巴张开，你就像。所以这有直接的联系。但你在说什么？我不会从看电影直接去躺下。嗯，你最终会在晚上结束时这样做，你从剧院回家，穿上你的小睡衣，然后爬上床。
Yeah, but it's a lot of time for the germs to get away. But the germs don't die that quick. I think they last longer, don't they? I don't know. I rely on something called my immune system and people have been doing this and living forever. What if you're smelling somebody's hair gel? My grandparents lived into their, well into their 90s,
是的，但细菌消散需要很多时间。但细菌不会死得那么快。我想它们存活的时间更长，不是吗？我不知道。我依靠所谓的免疫系统，人们一直这样做，并且活了很久。如果你闻到别人的发胶味怎么办？我的祖父母活到了，嗯，90多岁。
my great grandmother over 100, and they never owned a bottle of sanitizer. They didn't do any of this shit. They should have. Yeah, they should have. You're right, you're right, you're right. Long healthy lives, and they didn't obsess about it. I know, it's just a gross factor.
我的曾祖母超过100岁，他们从来没有买过一瓶消毒液。他们没做过这些破事。他们应该做的。是的，他们应该做的。你是对的，你是对的，你是对的。长寿健康，他们没有为此着迷。我知道，这只是恶心因素。
I wish I could not think about it, because I don't think I'm getting sick. I just think I'm preoccupied with gross thoughts. Yeah, I know, I wish I could not think about it, because I don't think I'm getting sick, I just think I'm preoccupied with gross thoughts. Yeah. I know, I know. Any other coffee chatter, should we get to our guests? We should get to our guests. I was, no, I could talk about the airplane travel thing, but no, let's go.
我希望我能不去想它，因为我不认为我会生病。我只是觉得我被恶心的想法占据了。是的，我知道，我希望我能不去想它，因为我不认为我会生病，我只是觉得我被恶心的想法占据了。是的。我知道，我知道。还有其他咖啡闲聊吗，我们该请嘉宾了吗？我们应该请嘉宾了。我当时，不，我可以谈谈飞机旅行的事，但算了，我们开始吧。
Okay, and I don't know if you heard it, but I did have an S on the end of that. Yes, guys, today it's a special treat. It's a two for Tuesday. Oh, wow! We didn't even have to pay extra. Yeah, yeah. We're going to double the pleasure, double the fun
好的，我不知道你有没有听到，但我确实在那个词后面加了一个S。是的，伙计们，今天是一个特别的款待。这是周二的双重惊喜。哦，哇！我们甚至不需要额外付费。是的，是的。我们要双倍的快乐，双倍的乐趣。
because we've got not just the one guess, we've got the two. And when I say two, it's kind of more like 10. Because of their combined accomplishments. Oh. Okay. On one side, he has sold more than 300 million records worldwide, okay? That's 26 golds, 43 platinum, two diamond.
因为我们不仅有一位嘉宾，我们有两位。当我说是两位时，更像是十位。因为他们加起来的成就。哦。好的。一方面，他在全球售出了超过3亿张唱片，好吗？那是26张金唱片，43张白金唱片，两张钻石唱片。
I gotta ask him what those are. Yeah, what's a diamond? He's also received six Grammys, two Oscars, a Tony, and yes, an Emmy to join the elite group of EGOT winners. He's a Kennedy Center honoree. He's received the French Legion of Honor and a knighthood from the Queen. For HIV AIDS, he's raised more than $565 million dollars. Not to be outdone,
我得问问他那些是什么。是的，什么是钻石唱片？他还获得了六项格莱美奖、两项奥斯卡奖、一项托尼奖，是的，还有一项艾美奖，加入了EGOT获奖者的精英群体。他是肯尼迪中心荣誉奖获得者。他获得了法国荣誉军团勋章和女王授予的爵士爵位。对于艾滋病，他筹集了超过5.65亿美元。不甘示弱，
she is one of music's most respected voices receiving 11 Grammy Awards, two Emmy Awards, an Oscar nomination, New York Times best-selling author. They've combined their superpowers to create a new album with a birthday of April 4th. They're here to talk about that and their incredible lives. I'm very excited and honored to introduce Brandi Carlile and Sir Elton John. What the hell? Can you believe it? What the hell? Good morning to you, Bozy.
她是音乐界最受尊敬的声音之一，获得了11项格莱美奖、两项艾美奖、一项奥斯卡提名，是《纽约时报》畅销书作家。他们结合了他们的超级力量，创作了一张新专辑，生日是4月4日。他们在这里谈论那个和他们不可思议的生活。我非常兴奋和荣幸地介绍布兰迪·卡莉和埃尔顿·约翰爵士。搞什么鬼？你敢相信吗？搞什么鬼？早上好，博齐。
Hi, guys. Well, hello. Guys, can you believe this? This is pretty cool. This is really cool. This is insane. And it's dark, so you believe this? This is pretty cool. This is really cool. This is insane.
嗨，伙计们。嗯，你好。伙计们，你们敢相信吗？这太酷了。这真的很酷。这太疯狂了。而且天黑了，所以你相信吗？这太酷了。这真的很酷。这太疯狂了。
And it's dark so you must be in London. Well Windsor, yeah. Yeah. Outside of London. Windsor. Oh, okay, sorry, yeah. I'm from Glen Ellyn which is outside of Chicago. It means nothing to Sean.
而且天黑了，所以你一定在伦敦。嗯，温莎，是的。是的。伦敦郊外。温莎。哦，好的，抱歉，是的。我来自芝加哥郊外的格伦埃林。这对肖恩来说毫无意义。
Nothing to Sean. And you're together too. This is, are you, what are you both doing right now? This is in conjunction with promoting the album that you're together too. This is, are you, what are you both doing right now? This is in conjunction with promoting the album, that you're together? It is in conjunction with promoting the album. So yeah, that's why we're talking to you guys. We're promoting and flouting.
对肖恩来说毫无意义。而且你们也在一起。这是，你们，你们现在都在做什么？这是为了宣传你们在一起的专辑吗？这是，你们，你们现在都在做什么？这是为了宣传专辑，你们在一起吗？这确实是为了宣传专辑。所以是的，这就是为什么我们和你们谈话。我们在宣传和炫耀。
This is so cool for us, you guys. This is really cool. Thank you. Huge fan. Like to say hello to Sean, who I haven't seen for years. I know, how are you, my friend? I know, I haven't seen for years. I know, how are you my friend? I know I haven't seen you in such a long time. I know.
这对我们来说太酷了，伙计们。这真的很酷。谢谢。我是超级粉丝。想向肖恩问好，我已经好几年没见他了。我知道，你好吗，我的朋友？我知道，我已经好几年没见了。我知道，你好吗，我的朋友？我知道我好久没见你了。我知道。
Sean, do you owe him money? I do owe him a little bit of money and a little bit of a good time. Yeah, he was a rent boy when I knew him. Oh. He's a lease boy now, so. By the way, still the same price. Yeah, wow.... Wow, wow.
肖恩，你欠他钱吗？我确实欠他一点钱，还有一点美好时光。是的，我认识他的时候他是个男妓。哦。他现在是租赁男孩了，所以。顺便说一句，价格还是一样。是的，哇……哇，哇。
Now wait, I have a great, this is so kooky. So Brandi, you know what? I'm going to tell this story when I first met you. Okay. So this is embarrassing for me. So we were at a fundraiser and we got sat next to each other, me and Scotty and you and your wife. And I sat there and like an idiot, I go,
现在等等，我有一个很棒的，这太古怪了。所以布兰迪，你知道吗？我要讲讲我第一次见到你的故事。好的。所以这对我很尴尬。我们在一个筹款活动上，我们被安排坐在一起，我和斯科蒂，还有你和你妻子。我坐在那里，像个白痴一样，我说，
and we were laughing and having a good time, I go, I'm so sorry, I'm an idiot, what do you do? And you, and you said, I'm in the music business. I'm like, oh, okay, cool. And then you introduced your wife, who's also lovely. And we had a great night. And then the next day, I go to this meeting at like,
我们当时在笑，玩得很开心，我说，我很抱歉，我是个白痴，你是做什么的？然后你，你说，我在音乐行业。我说，哦，好的，酷。然后你介绍了你的妻子，她也很可爱。我们度过了一个美好的夜晚。然后第二天，我去参加一个会议，在，
I don't know, Warner Brothers or something, and it's at a high-rise, and I look out the window, and the size of a building is a billboard with your face on it. And I'm like, I just sat next to her last night at dinner. And had no idea. I had no idea. Now, of course, I listen to all your songs,
我不知道，华纳兄弟还是什么地方，那是在一栋高楼里，我看向窗外，那栋楼的大小是一个印着你脸的广告牌。我就想，我昨晚才在晚餐时坐在她旁边。而且完全不知道。我完全不知道。现在，当然，我听了你所有的歌，
like when bananas on you after that. I've done lots of things. I've been a roofing laborer, a barista, a grocery store worker. I've done lots of things. It's good. Wait, are those things true, Brandi? Yeah.
就像在那之后对你着迷一样。我做过很多事。我做过屋顶工人、咖啡师、杂货店员工。我做过很多事。这很好。等等，那些事是真的吗，布兰迪？是的。
What kind of barista were you? Were you good at the baristaing? I always think I would be awful at that. Well it's all about tips. I burn myself every time. It's all about tips, so I was great. Yeah? Yeah. Oh yeah. Are you good working for the tips, it's all about tips, so I was great. Yeah? Yeah.
你做过什么样的咖啡师？你擅长做咖啡吗？我总觉得我会做得很糟糕。嗯，这全靠小费。我每次都会烫伤自己。这全靠小费，所以我很棒。是吗？是的。哦，是的。你擅长为了小费工作吗？我一直暗地里幻想成为一名服务员，这样我就可以研究每一桌客人，弄清楚他们需要我成为什么样的人才能得到最好的小费。就像不同的观众，你知道吗？天哪。是的，我们知道。
Oh yeah. Are you good working for the tips? I've always secretly had a fantasy to be a waiter just so I could work each table to figure out what they need me to be to get the best tip. Like separate audiences, you know? Jesus. Yeah, we know.
你很擅长那个？是的，我们知道在音乐行业，在娱乐产业，我们知道如何变色龙。我从来不明白为什么，因为我在餐馆工作过，为什么我们必须把小费合在一起，然后平分，你有没有在那种地方工作过？每个人把小费汇集在一起，然后平分。
You were great at that? Yeah, we know how to do this in the music business, in the entertainment industry, we know how to chameleon. I never understood why, because I worked at a restaurant, why we all have to combine our tips, and then you split, did you ever work in one of those places? Where you put all, everybody pools their tips, and then you split them.
我是不是应该说——这真的是运作方式吗？是的，我做服务员的时候就是这样。太糟糕了。我的执念是观察杰森，当人们描述现实世界的工作时，上帝保佑你，我爱你杰森，但你从来没有，他在演艺圈长大。
Am I supposed to say- Is that really the way it works? Yeah, it worked when I was a waiter. It was awful. My obsession is watching Jason, when people describe real world jobs, and God bless you and I love you Jason, but you've never, he grew up in the show biz.
他从小就是演员，从来没有过现实世界的工作，对吧杰森？你从来没有做过非演艺工作。威尔，你有没有做过拿小费的工作？去他的，没有，但我想说的是，我确实做过现实世界的工作。所以它是。是的，鸭子战壕，我知道，我知道。
He's been an actor since he was a kid and he's never had a real world, right Jason? You've never had non-acting jobs. Will, have you ever had a job where you get tips? Fuck no, but I'm saying the point is, I have had real world jobs though. So it is. Yeah, duck trenches, I know, I know.
好了，你们两个，我们来谈谈《谁相信天使》。这是你们的新专辑。专辑的概念是什么？这是怎么产生的？这是谁的好主意聚在一起？谁给谁打的电话？嗯，我是布兰迪的粉丝，也是布兰迪的朋友，
All right, you guys, you two, let's talk about Who Believes in Angels. This is your new album. What about the concept for the album? How did that come about? Whose great idea was this to get together? Who called who? Well, I've been a fan of Brandy and a friend of Brandy's
超过20年了，还有她的家人。哇。而且我，我一直想和她录音。当最后一次巡演在欧洲结束时，我有了制作这张专辑的想法。我已经预订了10月23日在洛杉矶的录音室。是的。我非常渴望和她一起做一张唱片。我多年来一直是她的粉丝。
for over 20 years and her family. Wow. And I've been, I've always wanted to record with her. And I had the idea of making the album when the final tour stopped in Europe. I'd already booked the studio in Los Angeles for October 23. Yeah. And I wanted to desperately make a record with her. I've been a fan of hers for years.
她一直是我的粉丝。我们在过程中加入了伯尼·托平，他是我长期的作词人，还有安德鲁·瓦特，制作人。所以我们四个人走进录音室，带着只有自我怀疑和犹豫。而且……我会找一张好专辑。
She's been a fan of mine. We included Bernie Torpen in the process, who's been my long time lyricist, and Andrew Watt, the producer. So there were four of us going into the studio with nothing but self doubt and hesitation. And... I'll look for a good album.
当我到达录音室时，我真的很累。我很暴躁。我很暴躁。我相当昏昏欲睡。前几天，这是一次艰难的经历，因为我的状态不好。我有太多的自我怀疑，不知道我是否能把这张专辑变成我想要的样子。
And when I got to the studio, I was really tired. I was grumpy. I was grumpy. I was fairly lethargic. And for the first few days, it was a hard experience because I was not in a good place. I had so much self-doubt, wondering whether I could shift this album into the way I wanted it to be.
最终，在他们把，我们拍摄了每一首歌的创作，每一次录音。所以我的行为都在那里供所有人观看。前五天之后，它突然点击了。人们真的非常支持我和我的行为。他们说服了我，我感觉状态很好。然后我们就咆哮了。我们在三周内写了14首歌，
And eventually, after they put, we filmed every song being written, every take being recorded. So my behavior is there for all to see. And after the first five days, it suddenly clicked. And people were really supportive of me and my behavior. And they talked me around and I felt in a good place. And then we just roared. We wrote 14 songs in three weeks,
其中10首进入了专辑。我们从零开始。所以这可能是我经历过的最伟大的创作体验之一。而且她是一台机器。她非常令人鼓舞。我是说，她的嗓音，她从不唱错音。她的乐句，我必须与之和声，
and 10 which made the album. And we started with nothing. So it was probably one of the greatest creative experiences I've ever had. And she is a machine. She is so incredibly inspiring. I mean, her vocals, she never does a bad vocal. Her phrasing, which I had to harmonize to,
对我来说太难了，以至于我真的把歌词撕了，叫她去死。他确实，他确实。噩梦。是的，噩梦。真的，你只是觉得，我不做那个？不。我不做那个？
was so difficult for me that I actually tore the lyric up and told her to fuck off. He did, he did. Nightmare. Yeah, nightmare. Really, you just were like, I'm not doing that? No. I'm not doing that?
是的，是的。然后在我撕掉它之后，我们不得不把它粘回去，因为我太真诚了。但等等，这通常是运作方式吗？你出现在录音室，什么都没有，然后你开始想出旋律或歌词，或者任何先打动你的东西？
Yeah, yeah. And then after I tore it up, we had to get it stuck back together again because I was being so genuineness. But wait, is that typically the way that it works? You show up in a studio and you've got nothing and you start to come up with either melodies or lyrics or whichever strikes you first?
不，你去那里时已经写好了一些东西。有时，布兰迪会那样做，她进去，我有时会带着我已经有几个想法走进录音室，但最近我大多只是在录音室里写。所有的歌都是二重唱吗，还是专辑里有一些独唱？每一首歌都是二重唱吗？
No, you go there with some things written. Sometimes, and Brandy does that, she goes in, and I sometimes go into the studio with I've had a couple of ideas, but mostly recently I've just write in the studio. And are all the songs duets or are there some solos on the album? Is every song a duet?
有10首曲目，所以我们做了一张专辑。第一面，以布兰迪的独唱歌曲结束。第二面，以我的独唱歌曲结束。哦，那很好。让布兰迪多说一点。哦，哇。我是说，布兰迪，我想说，嗨，首先，我好久没见你了。
There's 10 tracks, so we did like an album. Side one, it finishes with Brandy's solo song. Side two, finishes with my solo song. Oh, that's nice. Let Brandy talk a bit. Oh, wow. I mean, Brandy, I wanted to say, hi, first of all, I haven't seen you in a long time.
嗨，威尔。上次，嗨，你好吗？上次见到你，你，你在吉米在碗型剧场的纪念致敬音乐会上唱得非常美，那真是太棒了。太不可思议了。吉米·巴菲特。是的，吉米·巴菲特，伟大的吉米·巴菲特，他是我们的朋友，也是我们共同的朋友，简。
Hi, Will. Last time, hi, how are you? And last time I saw you, you were, you sang beautifully at Jimmy's Memorial Tribute Concert at the Bowl, which was just amazing. It was so incredible. Jimmy Buffett. Yeah, Jimmy Buffett, the great Jimmy Buffett, who was a friend of ours and our mutual friend, Jane.
布兰迪，感觉如何，我是说，你是一位如此有成就的歌手、词曲作者，你做过这一切，你是一位不可思议的表演者，但当你接到一个电话，我知道你和埃尔顿·约翰爵士已经是，正如他所说，20年的朋友了，但当你接到埃尔顿·约翰爵士的电话说，让我们做一张唱片，那一定有让你尴尬的风险，埃尔顿·约翰爵士。
And Brandi, what is it like, I mean, you're such an accomplished singer, songwriter, you've done it all, you're an incredible performer, but when you get a call, and I know you've been friends with Sir Elton John for, as he said, 20 years, but when you get a call from Sir Elton John saying, let's make a record, that must be at risk of embarrassing you, Saral and John.
当你接到那个电话，当那个消息传来，比如，嘿，我们要录一张唱片时，那是什么感觉？那是，如果他不是总是做他说要做的事，我不会相信，但他确实做了。他刚结束那场大规模的巡演，道奇体育场，格拉斯顿伯里，就像人生中真正的高光时刻。
What is that like when you get that call, when that comes through like, hey, we're going to make a record? It was, if he didn't always do what he says he's going to do, I wouldn't have believed it, but he does. And he was coming off of that massive tour, Dodger Stadium, Glastonbury, just like really highlight moments, like in anyone's life.
他带着所有的肾上腺素从这里出来。我想，嗯，他不会做的。他在说，但他当真吗？你们必须明白的是，我从11岁起就爱上了埃尔顿·约翰和伯尼·托平。他们是我写歌或接触乐器的唯一原因。
And he was coming out of this with all this adrenaline. And I thought, well, he's not going to do it. He's saying it, but does he mean it? And the thing you guys got to understand is I have loved Elton John and Bernie Toppins since I was 11 years old. They're the only reason I ever wrote a song or touched an instrument.
是的，我也是。所以这感觉真的很神秘，而且奇怪地美丽，在我人生的这个阶段，这就是我和埃尔顿在我们的关系中发生的事情，但这也有点道理。这比我能解释的要多，但这也比我能要求的要多。布兰迪，让你自己释放所有的创作本能是一件困难的事情吗？
Yeah, same. And so it feels really mystical and bizarrely beautiful that at this point in my life, that this is what's happened to me and Elton in our relationship, but also it kind of makes sense. And that's more than I can explain, but it's also more than I could have asked for. Was it a difficult thing to allow yourself, Brandi, to let all your creative instincts flow
像我想象的那样，当你独自工作时，它们会自由流动？当你与一个对你来说是英雄的人合作时，你能够放下那种障碍，让所有的本能飞翔吗？很长一段时间都没有。我是说，想象一下，你知道吗？
as freely as I imagine they flow when you're working by yourself? When you're collaborating with somebody that's such a hero to you, were you able to sort of like let that barrier drop down and let all the instincts fly? Not for a long time. I mean, imagine that, you know?
就像想想那会怎么发展。对我来说就像一场存在主义危机。它可能发展得很糟糕。就像我第一次把歌词放在埃尔顿·约翰面前，如果他不能为它写一首歌怎么办？对。她太鼓舞人心了，她太，
Like think how that could have gone. It was like an existential crisis for me. It could have gone really wrong. Like that first time I put a lyric down in front of Elton John, what if he hadn't have been able to write a song to it? Right. She's so inspiring and she's so,
你知道，我只是被她启发了，我，我一直被她的声音和写作所启发，但她的音乐性。我认为我们互相启发。这就是做这张唱片的全部意义，拥有我们作为艺术家的东西，然后把它放在另一个人身上。而且她很快，我是说她真的很快，
you know, I was just inspired by her, I've I was inspired by her, I've always been inspired by her voice and her writing, but her musicianship. And I think we both inspired each other. That was the whole point of doing the record, to have what we have as artists and then put it on the other person. And she's quick, I mean she's really quick,
她一次录音就完成了。太神奇了。你们俩都能很好地演唱许多不同类型的歌曲。有这么多不同的声音、流派和节奏。关于专辑会有什么样的声音和基调，有很多交流吗？是会有摇滚感、乡村感、民谣感吗？关于那个有什么讨论吗？这完全取决于埃尔顿有这个愿景。
and she does a vocal in like one take. It's amazing. You're both able to do so many different types of songs well. There's so many different sounds and genres and rhythms. Was there much communication about what type of sound and tone the album would have? Whether it would have a rock feel, a country feel, a ballad feel? Was there any discussion about that? It was all down to Elton had this vision.
起初他就像，好的，他试图概念化它会是什么，他说，好的，我们要像罗伯特·普兰特和艾莉森·克劳斯。然后他一周后会打电话给我说，不，不，不，是Eurythmics。然后他一周后会打电话给我说，不，是巴迪·霍利和帕齐·克莱恩。
It was like at first he was like, okay, he was trying to conceptualize what it would be and he goes, okay, we're gonna be like Robert Plant and Alison Krauss. And then he would call me a week later and go, no, no, no, it's the Eurythmics. And then he would call me a week later and go, no, it's Buddy Holly and Patsy Cline.
然后有一天他只是打电话给我说，不，它会是我们。让我们只是我们，但我们不会做任何人期望我们做的事情。然后愿景就清晰了。几年前，我给她买了一把电吉他，因为我想推动她，鼓励她弹电吉他，走出去，多摇滚一点。
And then one day he just called me and he said, no, it's going to be us. Let's have it just be us, but we're not going to do anything anybody expects from us. And then the vision just came clear. Years ago, I bought her an electric guitar because I wanted to push her and nudge her to play electric and get out there and rock a little more.
她有很棒的一面，我能看到，但没有表现出来。而且她，你知道，她成长了，她喜欢各种音乐。而且她打破了，听着，她在迪士尼音乐厅唱了乔尼·米切尔的整张《Blue》专辑，没有提词器，这需要该死的钢铁般的胆量，我告诉你。所以她有很大，很大的胆量，我告诉你。
And there's a great side of her that I could see that wasn't coming out. And she, you know, she's grown, she loves all sorts of music. And she's broken, listen, she sang Joni Mitchell's entire Blue album at Disney Hall without a teleprompter, which takes balls of fucking steel, I tell you. And so she's got big, big balls, I tell you.
专辑的新标题。不幸的是，她经常放屁，但这没关系。是的，是的，不。相信我。是的，是的。都在花絮里，对吧？我们马上回来。现在回到节目。你们俩是怎么认识的？她写了一封信给我，我了解她的音乐。我在拉斯维加斯做我的驻场演出，她说，你有没有考虑过演奏
New title for the album. The unfortunate thing is she breaks wind a lot, but that's okay. Yeah, yeah, no. Believe me. Yeah, yeah. It's all in the outtakes, right? And we will be right back. And now back to the show. How did you both first meet? She wrote me a letter and I was aware of her music. I was in Las Vegas doing one of my residency and she said, would you ever consider playing
我的一首歌？我回信说，或者打电话给她，我想，在上面放了一个电话号码，我说，嘿，是的，如果你能来拉斯维加斯，因为我被困在这里，我们可以一起做点什么。她来了，在我坐在钢琴前之前，我就爱上了她。这就像注定是一段持续了多年又多年，并且变得更好的友谊。
on a song of mine? And I wrote back and said, or phoned her, I think, put a phone number on it, and I said, hey, yeah, if you can come to Vegas, because I'm stuck here, we can do something together. And she came, and before I even sat at the piano, I fell in love with her. It was like it was destined to be a friendship that's lasted for years and years and years and gotten better.
这只是偶然，或者不管它是什么。机缘巧合。是的，你知道吗，我必须说，当我见到你布兰迪时，我也立刻爱上了你。你是那种非常可爱，充满光芒、爱和接纳的个性和人之一。花了我一点时间。花了我一点时间。花了一点时间。
And it was just a happenstance or whatever it was. Serendipity. Yeah, you know what, I have to say, when I met you Brandy too, I just immediately fell in love with you. You are one of those personalities and people that just are so lovely and filled with light and love and acceptance. Took me a minute. Took me a minute. Took a minute.
是的，我还没到那一步。我不得不对她热身，是的。我确实。我真的只是做了。而且她非常有创造力。这就是我喜欢的。不开玩笑。这太疯狂了，就像去拉斯维加斯看埃尔顿。
Yeah, I'm not there yet. I had to warm up to her, yeah. I did. I really just did. And she's creative as hell. That's what I love. No kidding. It was wild, like going to see Elton in Vegas.
我记得走下那条长长的走廊，我能听到他的声音，说话的声音，在我看到他之前。我小时候花了很多时间看《Live in Melbourne》和《Tantrums and Tiaras》以及他所有的采访。那是他的声音，我就想，哦，天哪，我一会儿就要转过弯了，埃尔顿·约翰就要坐在那里了。大约25，也许30年前，我在洛杉矶，年轻，失业或几乎失业的演员，我在比佛利山庄的一家餐馆，
I remember coming down that long hallway, and I could hear his voice, speaking voice, before I saw him. And I had spent so much time as a kid growing up with Live in Melbourne and Tantrums and Tiaras and all of his interviews. And it was his voice, and I was like, oh my God, I'm going to come around the corner in a minute, and Elton John is going to be sitting there. and tiaras and all of his interviews. About 25, maybe 30 years ago, I was in Los Angeles, young, unemployed or barely employed actor, and I was at a restaurant in Beverly Hills,
我不知道为什么。然后，约翰爵士，你进来了，你和一个朋友坐在桌子旁，然后你旁边有一张桌子，有一个保安。电话响了，他的电话，他接了电话，递给你，你讲了大约30秒电话，然后递回给那个人，
I don't know why. And, Sir John, you came in and you sat at a table with a friend and then you had like a security guy with you at a table next to you. And the phone rang and his phone, and he took the call, handed it to you, you spoke on the phone for like 30 seconds and handed it back to the guy,
我想，那就是我想要的。我想要一个家伙坐在我身后的桌子上。他感觉到了那个电话。专辑里有歌吗？顺便说一句，当你那样做时，当你那样合作时，想出一个歌词或旋律或任何东西，通过讨论，
and I thought, that's what I want. I want a guy sitting at a table behind me. He feels the call. Were there songs on the album? By the way, when you're doing that, when you're collaborating like that, isn't it difficult to come up with like a lyric or a melody or whatever, and through discussion,
不得不放弃你非常喜欢的东西，难道不困难吗？没有讨论。如果埃尔顿不喜欢，他只是大喊，切掉那一行，它就没了。真的吗？是的，但这很容易。没有什么我不喜欢的。
have to get rid of something that you love so much. Like how do you come to terms with that? There's no discussion. If Elton doesn't like it, he just yells, cut the line, and it's gone. Really? Yeah, but it was very easy. There wasn't anything I didn't like.
我们选择的所有10首歌都是显而易见的歌曲，其余的，它们还可以。我们有的那10首太棒了。所以不，我是说，不，我永远不会那样说。我是说，她给我的所有歌都很棒。他做决定非常，非常快。甚至不需要去想。所以没有时间去纠结
All the 10 songs that we chose were the obvious songs, and the rest, they're okay. The 10 that we had were fantastic. So no, I mean, no, I would never say that. I mean, all the songs she gave to me were amazing. He makes decisions very, very quickly. It's not really even to be thought about. So there's no time to really stew
在你的那种艺术，你知道，不管什么。他只是，它发生得非常快。他是一个快速，快速的词曲作者。是的。而且这不会有巡演，对吧？因为你没有更多的巡演了，对吧，埃尔顿·约翰爵士？我没有更多的巡演了。
in your kind of artistic, you know, whatever. He just, it happens very quickly. He's a quick, quick songwriter. Yeah. And there'll be no touring of this, right? Because there's no more touring for you, correct, Sir Elton John? There's no more touring for me.
我对此非常高兴。现在，嗯，你做到了。非常感谢你所有的演出。天哪，我去了最后一次巡演中的一场演出。太不可思议了。视频呢？人们还在制作视频，对吧？有关于那个的讨论吗？
And I'm very happy about that. Now what about, well, you've done it. Thank you very much for all your shows. My God, I went to one of the shows on this last tour. It was incredible. What about videos? Do folks make videos still, right? Is there talk about that?
是的，我们为这个制作了一个视频，它真的很棒。大卫·拉夏贝尔制作了视频，他制作了专辑封套。是的，当然我们会制作视频，当然我们会做一些电视节目，我们甚至可能在电视节目上表演。我喜欢那个。肖恩，你的钢琴弹得怎么样了？还可以。
Yeah, we've made a video for this, and it's really great. David Lashoppel did the video, and he did the album sleeve. Yeah, of course we'll do videos, and of course we'll do some TVs, and we may even play on a TV show. I love that. And Sean, how's your piano playing coming along? It's going okay.
是的，为他赢得了托尼奖。是的，他赢得了托尼奖。他确实。是吗？但是，嗯，肖恩，你的钢琴弹得怎么样了？还可以。还可以。是的，为他赢得了托尼奖。是的，他赢得了托尼奖。是的。他确实。是的，是的，他确实。他是一位了不起的钢琴家。不可思议。
Yeah, won him a Tony. Yeah, he won a Tony. He did. Yeah? But, um, and Sean, how's your piano playing coming along? It's going okay. It's going okay. Yeah, won him a Tony. Yeah, he won a Tony. Yeah. He did. Yeah, yeah, he did. He's an amazing piano player. Incredible.
他演奏了，他在塔巴斯科剧院做了《晚安奥斯卡》，这让他去年赢得了托尼奖。多么棒的演出！是的，宝贝！Sim up！是的，他演奏了《蓝色狂想曲》，独自一人，在三角钢琴上，就在那里，舞台中央。我们以前讲过这个故事，所以原谅我们，对我们的观众，原谅我们，但杰森
He played, he did a good night Oscar at the Tabasco Theater, which won him a Tony last year. What a show! Yeah, baby! Sim up! Yeah, he plays Rhapsody in Blue, all by himself, on a grand, right there, middle of the stage. We've told this story before, so forgive us and to our audience, forgive us, but Jason
坐在正前方，直接在我前面，我们去了首演之夜，那是，一旦结束，肖恩演奏了《蓝色狂想曲》，每个人都在欢呼，杰森转过身来，我们俩眼里都有泪水，他说，我们的演出结束了。是的，我们不能再取笑肖恩了。我们现在对他有太多的尊重了。太棒了。
was sitting right in front, directly in front of me, we went opening night, and it was, as soon as that was over and Sean had played Rhapsody in Blue and everybody was cheering, and Jason turned around, we both had tears in our eyes and he said, our show's over. Yeah, we can't make fun of Sean anymore. We've got too much respect for him now. It was so good.
顺便说一句，那是转瞬即逝的，因为我们又回到了原点。我过去常去肖恩在汉考克公园的家，过去常在那里弹钢琴。太棒了。这是同一栋房子。是的。你还在那里。太棒了。这是同一栋房子。是的。你还在那里。
By the way, and that was fleeting because we're right back where we started. I used to go around to Sean's house in Hancock Park and used to play the piano there. It was fantastic. This is the same house. It is. You're still there. It was fantastic. This is the same house. It is. You're still there.
是的，我还在那里。是的，然后我，然后你，我想我有一段时间的钢琴是你的，然后我把它卖了换了一个更大的。等等，等等，等等，等等。你有他的钢琴？我想是的，因为埃里克·麦柯马克，他在《威尔和格蕾丝》里，他，一些，
Yeah, I'm still here. Yes, and then I, and then you, I think the piano I had for a while was yours and then I sold it for a bigger one. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. You had his piano? I think so, because Eric McCormick, who was on Will and Grace, he, some,
就像每个人都在交易钢琴还是什么。不知何故，我最终得到了埃尔顿的，然后，然后我得到了一个新的。这是黑市钢琴交易吗？音乐家和艺术家之间发生了什么？发生了什么？或者其中一个，是的。但是是的，你过来弹了音乐
like everybody was trading pianos or something. Somehow I ended up with Elton's and then, and then I got a new one. What is this like a black market piano trade? What's happening here amongst musicians and artists? What's going on? Or one of, yeah. But yeah, you came over and played the music
给《夜访吸血鬼》。我被震撼了。你只是坐在我的钢琴前，开始弹奏半部音乐剧。我就想，你怎么能做到那样？这只是，哇。太不可思议了。在现实生活中看到那个真是令人难以置信。
to Interview with the Vampire. I was blown away. You just sat down at my piano and started playing half the musical. And I was like, how can you do that? It's just, wow. It was incredible. It's unbelievable to see that in real life.
太神奇了。你现在有什么样的钢琴？现在我有，哦，天哪，我太紧张了，我不记得了。哦，那是你。不，贝森朵夫。贝森朵夫，那是最好的钢琴。是的。除了雅马哈。
It's amazing. What kind of piano do you have now? Right now I have, oh my God, I'm so nervous, I can't remember. Oh, that's you. No, Boisendorfer. Boisendorfer, that's the best piano. Yeah. Apart from Yamaha.
是的，因为你在它的末端有额外的音符。是的，是的，是的。额外的音符。是的。真的吗？秘密音符。秘密音符。我比我想象的要笨。
Yeah, because you've got the extra notes down the end of it. Yes, yes, yes. Extra notes. Yeah. Really? Secret notes. Secret notes. I'm dumber than I thought I was.
它是哪里制造的？等等，它的名字是什么？贝森朵夫。或者你有一架可爱的贝森朵夫。如果我有一美元。而且这个有额外的秘密键。这个有三个额外的键。它更长。
Where is it made? Wait, what is the name of it? Bosendorfer. Or you have a lovely Bosendorfer. If I had a dollar. And this one has extra secret keys. This one has three extra keys. It's longer.
当然我们有。当然我们是德国人。当然我们有额外的键。你不想知道它们来自哪里吗？所以布兰迪和埃尔顿，你们，你们多次同台演出。你们有没有想到的你们一起的最喜欢的表演？我们没有表演过很多次。我们做了道奇体育场。
Of course we do. Of course we're German. Of course we have extra keys. Wouldn't you like to know where they came from? So Brandi and Elton, you guys, you've been on stage together multiple times. Has there been a favorite performance you guys have had together that you can think of? We haven't performed many times. We did Dodger Stadium.
道奇体育场是我最喜欢的，当她唱《Don't Let the Song Go Down on Me》时，因为她，Lady Gaga以前做过，而且不可思议，她没空，所以我问布莱恩她是否可以。她更便宜。便宜得多。便宜得多。便宜，但她摧毁了这首歌。
Dodger Stadium has been my favorite when she sang Don't Let the Song Go Down on Me because she, Lady Gaga had done it before and was incredible and she wasn't available so I asked Brian if she was. She was cheaper. Much cheaper. A lot cheaper. Cheaper but she destroyed the song.
更渴望。太不可思议了。是的。我们第一次真正一起唱歌，我不知道你是否记得这个确切的，我们第一次在现实生活中真正一起唱歌是在乔尼的客厅里。乔尼·米切尔。
Much more eager. It was incredible. Yeah. The first time we actually sang together though, I don't know if you remember this exact, the exact first time we actually ever sang together in real life was in Joni's living room. Joni Bichia.
在那首乡村歌曲上。不，拜托。没有多少人能说出那句话，不是吗？不。不，多么棒的句子。那是一首我从小就喜欢的古老乡村歌曲，叫《You Can Tell Your Friend They're With You》，
On that country song. No, come on. Not many people can say that, can they? No. No, what a sentence. It was an old country song that I've loved since I was a little kid called You Can Tell Your Friend They're With You,
《He'll Have To Go》。是的，《He'll Have To Go》，是的。乔尼唱了《Love Potion Number Nine》和《Summertime》。那只是其中最，是的。而且她，音乐让乔尼重新聚在一起，还有她的理疗师。但这个在我左边的女孩，过去常煽动乔尼重新聚在一起，还有她的理疗师。但这个在我左边的女孩，过去常煽动乔尼果酱，人们过去常来，
He'll Have To Go. Yes, He'll Have To Go, yeah. And Joni sang Love Potion Number Nine and Summertime. And it was just one of the most, yes. And she, music got Joni back together again as well as her physio. But this girl here to my left, who used to instigate Joni back together again, as well as her physio. But this girl here, to my left, used to instigate Joni jams where people used to come up,
你必须演奏，你们都必须在乔尼·米切尔面前唱歌，这很可怕。那很多。哦，天哪。但这是最伟大的事情之一，你会让哈里·汉考克在那里，你会让查克·奥康在那里，你会让邦妮·雷特在那里，你会让……
you had to play, you all had to sing in front of Joni Mitchell, which is terrifying. That's a lot. Oh my God. But it was one of the greatest things, and you'd have Harry Hancock up there, you'd have Chuck O'Conn, you'd have Bonnie Raitt, you'd have...
你。不，你会……你。哦，有……你。不。笑声 有那个。保罗·麦卡特尼会来。保罗·麦卡特尼，是的。太神奇了。黛比·吉布森。
You. No, you'd... You. Oh, there's have... You. No. LAUGHTER There's that. Paul McCartney would come. Paul McCartney, yeah. That's amazing. Debbie Gibson.
太神奇了。天哪，你对着这个唱了整张《Blue》唱片。我是说，那是一张多么不可思议的唱片。嗯，一张不可思议的唱片，但她做到了，显然，在迪士尼音乐厅她在乔尼旁边做的时候，它是无懈可击的，我只是说，你知道，钢铁般的胆量是荒谬的。而且没有提词器，我永远不会那样做
That's amazing. God, you sang the whole Blue record to this. I mean, that's what an incredible record that is. Well, an incredible record, but she did it, obviously, next to Joni at Disney Hall when she did it, and it was faultless, and I just said, you know, ball to steal is ridiculous. And without a teleprompter, I would never have done that
没有提词器，这是最不可思议的勇敢和大胆的事情。然后她在卡内基音乐厅也做了。太惊人了，乔尼再高兴不过了。她复苏了乔尼。我喜欢那个。哇。嗯，你知道，你提出了一个有趣的观点。我一直想知道关于提词器是用于歌词
without a teleprompter, and it was the most incredibly brave and courageous thing to do. And then she did it at Carnegie Hall as well. It was phenomenal, and Joni couldn't have been happier. She resuscitated Joni. I love that. Wow. Well, you know, you bring up an interesting point. I've wondered that about the about the teleprompter is for lyrics
和东西。这在巡演音乐家中有多普遍？它变得越来越普遍。我开始看到它在所有的致敬演出中发生。但现在，现在我认为它只是它的一部分，因为它们看起来像舞台上的监视器，所以你看不出来，你知道。但我确定这很有趣，因为很多音乐家还没有弄清楚
and stuff. How common is that on on tour with musicians? It's getting more and more common. I started seeing it happen at all the tributes and stuff like that. But now it's that now I think it's just kind of a part of it because they look like monitors on stage, so you can't tell, you know. But I'm sure that it's interesting because a lot of musicians haven't figured out
表演时如何不看它们，所以我讨厌看到那个。但与此同时，它提供了一些自发性，因为音乐家可以从观众那里接受点歌，并实际演奏一首歌。对，他们可以加载它。杰森去治疗时使用提词器，对吗，杰森？
how to not look at them when they're performing, so I hate seeing that. But at the same time, it provides some spontaneity because then a musician can take a request out of the audience and actually play a song. Right, and they can just load it in. Jason uses a prompter when he goes to therapy, is that right, Jason?
你刚才告诉我的。不。不。不。不。很难把所有的谎言放在一起，是的。不。
You just told me that. No. No. No. No. No. It's hard to keep all the lies together, yeah. No.
不。你能想象吗？我从观众那里得到点歌，你能弹《Piano Man》吗？我说，找错人了。没门。找错人了。
No. No. Could you imagine? I get requests from the audience, can you play Piano Man? And I say, wrong guy. No way. Wrong guy.
不。你不可能那样做。有人让我弹过一次《Piano Man》，是的。没门！我不得不和比利弹过很多，很多，很多，很多次《Piano Man》。保安。我不能自己弹。是的，保安。
No. No way you do not. Someone asked me to play Piano Man once, yeah. No way! I had to play Piano Man with Billy many, many, many, many times. Security. I couldn't play on my own. Yeah, security.
哦，天哪。那太疯狂了。现在，你，你说你拍摄了整个录音过程，那会发生什么？但疯狂的是，我从来没看到过摄像机。我们不知道它们在哪里，它们是。
Oh my God. That is crazy. Now, what are you, you say you filmed the entire recording process, what's going to happen with that? But the crazy thing is, I never saw a camera. We don't know where they were, they were.
它们是固定的微小东西。所以我们他妈的不断忘记它们，只是我们的行为反映在其中。这是一个非常奇怪的概念。而且我不知道，我想因为那个原因，它就像，这是一次狂野的旅程。专辑末尾有一首歌，是我的独唱歌曲。
They were fixed little tiny things. So we fucking forgot about them constantly and just our behavior was reflected in that. It was a very strange concept. And I don't know, I think for that reason, it's like, it's a wild ride. There's a song at the end of the album, which is my solo song.
布兰迪有一首独唱歌曲，第一面的Yender，关于她的女儿，她的大女儿长大并离开。告诉她关于它的事，那只是一首美丽的歌。哦，它只是，它就像关于那一刻，就像当你有了孩子，就像，他们以某种方式离开你。甚至，它甚至可以在他们年轻时发生
Brandy has a solo song, the Yender, the Side One, about her daughter, her eldest daughter growing up and leaving. Tell her about it, it's just a beautiful song. Oh, it's just, it's like about that moment, like when you have kids, like where it's like, they depart you in some way. Even, it can even happen when they're young
而你既如此崩溃又如此自豪，你不知道该选哪种感觉。就是关于那个。我喜欢那个。你是说空巢？有点，但它也可以在早期发生。就像他们第一次选择你不相信的东西，或者挑选你不喜欢的唱片
and you're so devastated and you're so proud at the same time and you don't know which feeling to pick. It's about that. I love that. You mean empty nesting? Kind of, but it can happen early on too. Like the first time that they choose something you don't believe in or pick a record you don't like
或者决定在你想去旅行时留在家里。是的，那些时刻太悲伤了，但也太，他太自豪了。太真实了。我四岁的孩子今天早上，这有点令人心碎。我四岁的孩子今天早上，这有点令人心碎。我四岁的孩子对我说，他刚醒来
or decide to stay home on a trip when you wanted to come. Yeah, those moments are so sad, but also so, he's so proud. It's so true. My four year old this morning, it was kind of heartbreaking. My four year old this morning, it was kind of heartbreaking. My four year old said to me, he was just waking up
他有点依偎在我身边，我在亲吻他的头，亲吻他的头发，我说，嗨伙计，早上好，早上。然后他的眼睛甚至没睁开，他只是说，不要再亲了。这就是我在说的。我就想，哇，好的，好吧。天哪，那听起来像是一段漫长的婚姻。
and he was kind of snuggled up against me and I was kissing his head, kissing his hair and I was like, hi buddy, good morning, morning. And then his eyes weren't even open and he just goes, no more kissing. That's what I'm talking about. And I was like, wow, okay, all right. God, that sounds like a long marriage.
我在专辑末尾写了一首歌，我只是得到歌词，我只是太，伯尼教我歌词叫《When This Old World Is Done With Me》，所以我写了诗句，比如，哦，这真的很漂亮，然后我到了副歌，当然它是关于我的死亡。
I wrote a song at the end of the album, and I just get the lyrics, and I'm just too, Bernie's taught me lyrics called When This Old World Is Done With Me, and so I'm writing the verse, like, oh, this is really pretty, and then I get to the chorus, and of course it's about my death.
我在专辑末尾写了一首歌，我刚拿到歌词，伯尼教我的歌词叫《当这个旧世界厌倦了我》，我正在写主歌，觉得，哦，这真的很美，然后我写到了副歌，当然，那是关于我的死亡。
And when you get to my age, which is near 100, you think, how much time have I got left? And you've got children, you've got a wonderful husband, you just think about mortality. And so when I got to the chorus, I just broke down for 45 minutes and it all unfilmed. Cried hard. Oh wow.
到了我这个年纪，快100岁了，你会想，我还有多少时间？你有孩子，有很棒的丈夫，你只会想到死亡。所以当我唱到副歌时，我崩溃了45分钟，一切都失控了。哭得很厉害。噢，天哪。
And we just, yeah. When do we, so what is the plan with this footage? I think I want everybody to see it because it's really human, like deeply flawed and embarrassing and the kind of shit that you do when you forget that there is a camera on is what's really interesting.
我们就是，是的。我们什么时候，那么这个片段有什么计划吗？我想让每个人都看到它，因为它非常人性化，有深刻的缺陷和尴尬，当你忘记有摄像机在拍时所做的那些事，才是真正有趣的地方。
But that moment, I got to be in there and I witnessed that moment because when we were making the record, I would sit behind him when he was writing his melodies and try to like remember some of the ones that were really hitting me hard. And I was recording him on the melody of this song because I thought, okay, well,
但在那一刻，我能在那里，我见证了那一刻，因为我们在制作唱片时，他写旋律时我会坐在他身后，试着记住那些真正打动我的旋律。我当时正在录下这首歌的旋律，因为我想，好吧，
I want to remember this melody so that in case he moves on to another one, he can remember how good it was. And he got to the end of that chorus and his voice started to shake and I thought, oh, he's going, like he's going to really go. And he went into a real moment of a... And she came over and she said,
我想记住这个旋律，以防他换了另一个，他还能记得它有多好。他唱到副歌结尾时，声音开始颤抖，我想，噢，他要，他真的要动情了。他进入了一个真正的时刻……然后她走过来，她说，
don't worry, you've got at least another six months. That's great, that's great. Hold on to promotion. The worst part is she was looking at an app that was telling you real time when it was going to happen. That was scary. And I said, no, you're not in the will. Um...
别担心，你至少还有六个月。太好了，太好了。坚持住，还要宣传呢。最糟糕的是，她当时正在看一个应用程序，实时显示什么时候会发生。那太可怕了。我说，不，你不在遗嘱里。嗯……
LAUGHTER Good for Larry. Well, needless to say, not to be maudlin and we can push past this afterwards, if in the sort of the plan of using all your years as well as you possibly could. Sir Elton John, my goodness, what an enormous list of accomplishments
笑声 为拉里感到高兴。好吧，不用说，不是要伤感，之后我们可以跳过这个话题，如果是在尽可能好地利用你所有岁月的计划中。埃尔顿·约翰爵士，天哪，多么庞大的成就清单
you've done thus far with plenty of time left. Yeah, plenty of time left. You've contributed for three lifetimes, so rest assured. This is, by leave me, this is one of my biggest accomplishments with her. Accomplishments. Yeah. Well, we cannot wait to listen to it. Do you have, Sir Alan, can I just ask you quickly,
你到目前为止已经完成了，而且还有很多时间。是的，还有很多时间。你已经贡献了三辈子的心血，所以请放心。这是，相信我，这是我和她最大的成就之一。成就。是的。好吧，我们迫不及待想听了。你有，艾伦爵士，我能快速问你一下吗，
if you don't mind, when you, and Brandy alluded to it before, you being such a sort of a hero of hers, musically and inspiration, and Sean, you too, also as a musician, when you, and you have been such a, your music is such a big part of all of our lives for so long in ways that we don't even know.
如果你不介意的话，当你，布兰迪之前也提到过，你作为她心目中的英雄，在音乐和灵感上，肖恩，你也是，作为一名音乐家，当你，而且你一直是一个，你的音乐在很长一段时间里一直是我们所有人生活的重要组成部分，以我们甚至不知道的方式。
Like you've just, you really sort of weaved right into the fabric of all of our lives. Do you have moments when you're moving through the world, you're in a, you're somewhere and your song comes on, you're in a car, you're in a restaurant, you're in a shop, you're somewhere. How does it strike you when you hear your music, especially stuff that was from a long time ago,
就像你真的已经融入了我们所有人的生活。当你走在世界上，你在某个地方，你的歌响起了，你在车里，在餐厅，在商店，在某个地方。当你听到你的音乐时，尤其是很久以前的作品，你有什么感觉？
what are those moments like hearing your music? It's great, I don't listen to my stuff very often, I don't listen to the radio very often, but when you're in an elevator and you think, what the fuck is that? And it's Daniel, you feel very proud. No, I don't listen to my stuff, but I'm is that? And it's Daniel, you feel very proud. Yeah. You know, I don't listen to my stuff,
听到你的音乐是什么感觉？很棒，我不常听自己的东西，我不常听广播，但当你在电梯里，你会想，那是什么鬼东西？结果是《丹尼尔》，你会感到非常自豪。不，我不听我的东西，但我是那是？结果是《丹尼尔》，你会感到非常自豪。是的。你知道，我不听我的东西，
but I'm very proud of what we've written, and I love to hear it, as long as it's not being played by myself. But it's, yeah, I've done so much in my life, and yeah, there's so much more to do. And she's inspired me to go ahead with this record, and I think this is the best record I've made in 40 years. So there you go. Oh wow.
但我为我们写的东西感到非常自豪，我喜欢听它，只要不是我自己放的。但是，是的，我一生中做了很多事，而且，是的，还有更多的事情要做。她激励我继续制作这张唱片，我认为这是我40年来制作的最好的唱片。所以就是这样。噢，天哪。
By the way, glad you mentioned Daniel. I think that probably a thousand times in my life, anytime I've met somebody named Daniel, they say, Daniel, my brother, you are older than me. Every single time. Yeah, for sure. We'll be right back. And back to the show.
顺便说一句，很高兴你提到了《丹尼尔》。我想我一生中大概有一千次，每当我遇到叫丹尼尔的人，他们都会说，丹尼尔，我的兄弟，你比我大。每一次都是这样。是的，肯定的。我们马上回来。回到节目。
So you guys have, your friendship is, did you say it's 20 years you guys have been buddies? Over than that. Is that right? Somewhere around that. No, over than that. More than that. Maybe more than that, yeah.
所以你们，你们的友谊是，你说你们当朋友20年了？比那更久。是吗？大概那个时候。不，比那更久。不止那个。也许不止那个，是的。
My goodness. Because that was, I was in Vegas. Yeah, you were in Vegas. than that. Maybe more than that. Yeah. My goodness. Because that was, I was in Vegas. Yeah, you were in Vegas. Yeah. And we had kind of, yeah. So yeah, I thought that. Yeah, it's longer than that.
天哪。因为那是，我在拉斯维加斯。是的，你在拉斯维加斯。比那更久。也许不止那个。是的。天哪。因为那是，我在拉斯维加斯。是的，你在拉斯维加斯。是的。我们有点，是的。所以是的，我想到了。是的，比那更久。
Do your kids know each other? Yeah. They must, yeah. You guys go on vacations all the time together? They come to, we have a house in Nice in the south of France, and Brian and Catherine and the girls come down every summer, and we have the time of our lives. Oh my God. I love that.
你们的孩子认识吗？是的。他们肯定认识，是的。你们经常一起去度假吗？他们来，我们在法国南部的尼斯有一栋房子，布莱恩和凯瑟琳还有女孩们每年夏天都会来，我们度过了人生中最美好的时光。噢，天哪。我喜欢那样。
I love that. I stayed in a house, I stayed in a house right close to your house, Sir Elton John, a couple years ago I was working on a job for like six months and this French caretaker of this house kept saying, that is Sir Elton John's house right there. I didn't ring the bell. What about, do either one of you need
我喜欢那样。我住在一栋房子里，离你的房子很近，埃尔顿·约翰爵士，几年前我工作了大约六个月，这栋房子的法国看管人一直说，那就是埃尔顿·约翰爵士的房子。我没按门铃。那么，你们俩需要
any parenting tips from the other person? How does that go? Do the kids get along? Kids love each other. Kids really do. My boys are a little older than Brandy's girls, but my boys are really good with children. And Zachary's not here at the moment.
对方的育儿建议吗？进展如何？孩子们相处得好吗？孩子们很喜欢对方。孩子们真的很好。我的男孩们比布兰迪的女孩们大一点，但我的男孩们对孩子很好。扎卡里现在不在这里。
He's at school, but Elijah's here. And he just loves playing with the girls. There's no problem with that. They get on like a house on fire. And Brandy's girls are so, Brandy and Catherine's girls, I should say, are absolute angels. I mean, they're just beautiful girls.
他在学校，但以利亚在这里。他很喜欢和女孩们玩。那没问题。他们相处得非常好。布兰迪的女孩们，我应该说是布兰迪和凯瑟琳的女孩们，简直是天使。我的意思是，她们是非常漂亮的女孩。
The first time I went to go visit David and Elton in France with Catherine and my girls, we landed and we went downstairs at this table, this beautifully adorned table for breakfast. I mean, everything is like decked out. There's like designer napkins and it's like unbelievable. You wouldn't believe it. And I had a three-year-old at the time, and she was at that table for three seconds before,
我第一次和凯瑟琳还有我的女孩们去法国拜访大卫和埃尔顿时，我们落地后下楼来到这张桌子前，这张装饰精美的早餐桌。我的意思是，一切都装饰得很好。有设计师餐巾，简直不可思议。你不会相信的。我当时有个三岁的孩子，她在桌子旁待了三秒钟，
without any warning, she projectile vomited all over the entire thing. He didn't even pretend it was okay, he was just like. God damn it. But no, he and David were so sweet about it, and they calmed our anxiety, but I mean, I died a thousand deaths when that happened. Poor little fans.
没有任何预兆，她就喷射性呕吐在整个桌子上。他甚至没有假装没关系，他只是像。该死。但不，他和大卫对此非常贴心，他们平息了我们的焦虑，但我的意思是，当那件事发生时，我尴尬得想死。可怜的小粉丝。
You remember that. That's all sweet. Wait, you know, Elton, you know, I just, I go for walks a lot around my neighborhood because you can, and I just put on this album that I bought when I think I was a senior in high school called Red Strikes Back. Oh yeah. It's one of my favorite albums you ever did. Oh, thank you. One of my favorite songs, I never hear it anywhere.
你还记得那个。那很贴心。等等，你知道，埃尔顿，你知道，我经常在我的社区周围散步，因为可以，我只是放了这张我高中毕业时买的专辑，叫《Red Strikes Back》。噢，是的。这是你做过的我最喜欢的专辑之一。噢，谢谢。我最喜欢的歌之一，我从没在任何地方听到过。
It's so perfectly written as the Heavy Traffic song. Yeah, yeah, thank you. I mean, that's like a massive, massive hit song that was never, I don't know, was it ever released as a single? No, there was lots of songs on that album, Japanese Hands and stuff like that. Yes, Japanese Hands is great too.
它写得太完美了，就是那首《Heavy Traffic》。是的，是的，谢谢。我的意思是，那是一首非常非常热门的歌，从来没有，我不知道，它发行过单曲吗？没有，那张专辑里有很多歌，比如《Japanese Hands》之类的。是的，《Japanese Hands》也很棒。
There are lots of deep cuts. I mean, I've had a lot of hit singles, but probably the best songs are on the deep cuts. Oh yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. For sure, for sure. And of course, Give Up the Ghost is one of my favorite albums. Yeah.
有很多深层曲目。我的意思是，我有很多热门单曲，但最好的歌可能都在深层曲目里。噢，是的，是的。是的，是的，是的，是的，是的。肯定的，肯定的。当然，《Give Up the Ghost》是我最喜欢的专辑之一。是的。
Oh, thank you. It's true, it's true, one of my favorite albums. So Brandi, growing up in Washington, did you think that you would be at this, did you allow yourself to sort of dream about where you sit now in the industry, the level of respect and accomplishment, and how did that,
噢，谢谢。这是真的，这是真的，我最喜欢的专辑之一。那么布兰迪，在华盛顿长大，你有没有想过你会达到这个程度，你是否允许自己去梦想你现在在行业中的位置，那种受尊重和成就的水平，以及它是如何，
well, I guess just answer that one first. accomplishment and how did that, how did, well, I guess just answer that one first. You know, did you allow yourself to dream this high? Yes, the nuanced things like respect or credibility or things I value so much now, I hadn't really fantasized about, but I would close my eyes and dream of myself on stage at Madison Square Garden. I would think of myself like I would visualize myself winning a Grammy
好吧，我想先回答那个问题。成就，以及它是如何，它是如何，好吧，我想先回答那个问题。你知道，你允许自己梦想得这么高吗？是的，像尊重或信誉这样微妙的事情，或者我现在非常看重的事情，我并没有真正幻想过，但我会闭上眼睛，梦想自己站在麦迪逊广场花园的舞台上。我会想，我会想象自己赢得格莱美奖，
and thanking Elton John before I ever met Elton. I was like, oh yeah, I pictured I would get up on stage and thank Elton John and the Indigo Girls. And I was like maybe 13 years old. So I visualized a lot of what has happened, oddly, but, and I don't understand or profess to know why that is. But yes, I did allow myself to dream really big from that single wide mobile home.
并在见到埃尔顿之前就感谢埃尔顿·约翰。我当时大概13岁，我就想，噢，是的，我设想我会走上舞台，感谢埃尔顿·约翰和Indigo Girls。所以我设想了很多已经发生的事情，奇怪的是，而且我不明白或声称知道为什么会这样。但是是的，我确实允许自己从那个单宽移动房屋里做很大的梦。
I love that. Yeah, I wonder if the visualization, if you feel, is a really important part of it. And I'd ask you the same, Sir Elton John. Did you allow yourself to dream as big as well? And for our listeners, can you speak about what that kind of big word nowadays is, manifestation? I don't know if you guys subscribe to that,
我喜欢那样。是的，我想知道可视化，如果你觉得，是其中非常重要的一部分。我也想问你同样的问题，埃尔顿·约翰爵士。你也允许自己做那么大的梦吗？对于我们的听众，你能谈谈现在那个大词是什么吗，显化？我不知道你们是否认同这一点，
but having those goals and this vision and belief in yourself, what size role did that play, do you think, in both of your successes? I never imagined myself as a solo artist. When I was in my group, Bluesology, I took the big risk of going up to Liberty Records, saying, I want to write songs, I'm so fed up with playing in a band
但拥有这些目标和愿景以及对自己的信念，你认为这在你们俩的成功中扮演了多大的角色？我从未想象过自己会成为一名独唱艺术家。当我在我的乐队Bluesology时，我冒了很大的风险去Liberty唱片公司，说，我想写歌，我受够了在一个不想去任何地方的乐队里演奏，
that doesn't want to go anywhere, and I can sing too, and so the guy, as you know, cause it's an old story, gave me the envelope with Berners Lyrics in it. And then when we wrote songs, I had to go out and nothing was happening, I had to go out and play them live,, I had to go out and play them live, so I had to form a band.
而且我也会唱歌，所以那个人，如你所知，因为这是一个老故事，给了我那个装有伯尼歌词的信封。然后当我们写歌时，我不得不出去，什么也没发生，我不得不出去现场演奏它们，所以我不得不组建一个乐队。
And I really didn't have any visions of being Elton John's superstar, it just happened very, very quickly. And so, it was like, it was so exciting, because I came to America, and there was Neil Diamond introducing me, there was Brian Wilson, there was Linda Ronstadt, there was Leon Russell,
我真的没有任何成为埃尔顿·约翰超级巨星的愿景，它只是发生得非常非常快。所以，这就像，太令人兴奋了，因为我来到美国，有尼尔·戴蒙德介绍我，有布莱恩·威尔逊，有琳达·朗斯塔特，有莱昂·拉塞尔，
all those kind of people that were my heroes. And suddenly I was there. I mean, it took me a couple of years to establish myself all over America. But it was like, I was a kid in a candy store. I never really visualized Elton John being a big star. It all happened by accident. It really happened by accident, which was lovely.
所有那些曾经是我的英雄的人。突然间我就在那里了。我的意思是，我花了几年的时间才在美国各地站稳脚跟。但这就像，我是一个在糖果店里的孩子。我从未真正设想过埃尔顿·约翰会成为大明星。这一切都是偶然发生的。它确实是偶然发生的，这很可爱。
I was wondering about that too. Yeah, and I would imagine by accident, it really happened by accident. Which was lovely. That's a good question, I was wondering about that too. Yeah, and I would imagine the preservation of your smaller image, your more human image, your younger image, I would imagine has been, remains to be a very important part of not only your identity, but your ability to be creative and your ability to write and to constantly be connected
我也在想那个。是的，我想象偶然，它确实是偶然发生的。这很可爱。那是个好问题，我也在想那个。是的，我想象对你较小形象、更人性化形象、更年轻形象的保护，我想象这不仅是你身份的重要组成部分，也是你创造能力、写作能力以及不断与你开始时的人保持联系的能力的重要组成部分，
to the person that the public does not know, the person who you started as. That's gotta be a big important part for both of your careers, yeah? When I became successful very quickly, and this is in the documentary, Never Too Late, we did so much work in five years and went to the pinnacle of fame in five years and I lost the person that I was
那对你们俩的职业生涯来说一定是非常重要的一部分，对吧？当我很快取得成功时，这在纪录片《Never Too Late》里有提到，我们在五年内做了很多工作，在五年内达到了名声的巅峰，我失去了最初的那个我，
originally and that was very hard for me and it took me loads of years to get that back and I got it back when I got sober which is 35 years this year hopefully. And so yeah, the little boy inside of me had vanished but the little boys come back and everybody needs that little child inside them to keep them going and unfortunately I lost him and it made me very unhappy and very depressed but I still kept working, I still kept making records and touring, and so the music kept me alive until I finally came to my senses.
那对我来说非常困难，我花了很多年才找回它，当我戒酒时我找回了它，今年是第35年，希望如此。所以是的，我内心的小男孩消失了，但小男孩回来了，每个人都需要内心那个小孩子来支撑他们，不幸的是我失去了他，这让我非常不快乐和抑郁，但我仍然坚持工作，我仍然坚持制作唱片和巡演，所以音乐让我活了下来，直到我终于清醒过来。
And now my life is incredible. I mean, I couldn't have a better life than I could. I wake up every morning with my children and David and all the people that worked for me, the nicest people in the world. I am the luckiest person in the world. I am blessed. So yeah, and that little boy is very happy.
现在我的生活令人难以置信。我的意思是，我不可能有比这更好的生活了。我每天早上醒来，和我的孩子们、大卫以及所有为我工作的人在一起，他们是世界上最好的人。我是世界上最幸运的人。我被祝福了。所以是的，那个小男孩非常快乐。
Yeah. That's great, I love that. And Brandi, I'm sure that little child in you stays vibrant and loud. She's hanging out right now. She is like riding shotgun. She's like, this is the, you know, I've always tried to kind of like,
是的。太棒了，我喜欢那样。布兰迪，我相信你内心那个小孩子依然充满活力和响亮。她现在就在那儿。她就像坐在副驾驶座上。她就像，这是，你知道，我一直试图，
keep the young child in me like at bay long enough to do my job and get through the things that are important to me, you know. But for this one I've just let that girl come to the surface totally because I'm getting to hang out with Elton John. And that's an unbelievable realization of a dream. And it's really been like a life-affirming thing, you know? And also that young version of yourself gets clearer when you have kids too, you know?
让内心那个年轻的孩子保持足够长的时间，以便做好我的工作，度过对我重要的事情，你知道。但对于这次，我完全让那个女孩浮出水面，因为我有机会和埃尔顿·约翰在一起。这是一个令人难以置信的梦想实现。这真的是一件肯定生命的事情，你知道吗？而且当你有了孩子时，那个年轻版本的自己也会变得更清晰，你知道吗？
You just like try not to project onto them, but it's hard not to see a mini me sometimes. Yeah. Yeah. I'm sure, I'm sure. Help that. Well, God, you know, there's, I'm just looking at you two going, there's such a very, very, very small group of people
你只是尽量不要投射到他们身上，但有时很难不看到一个迷你版的自己。是的。是的。我相信，我相信。帮助那个。好吧，天哪，你知道，有，我看着你们两个，心想，世界上有非常非常非常少的一群人，
in the world that have gifts they leave behind that will last forever. I mean, just for decades. Immortal. Yeah, and to have a part of you live on in music is so rare that people, a lot of people try to achieve that level and they just don't. And so it's just incredible, incredible to see you guys. And now together, it's great.
他们留下的天赋将永远存在。我的意思是，仅仅几十年。不朽。是的，让你的部分生命在音乐中延续是如此罕见，以至于很多人试图达到那个水平却做不到。所以看到你们真是太不可思议了。现在在一起，太棒了。
Thank you. Yeah. Thanks, Sean. Yeah. That's it. And I'm going to try drugs for the first time. Oh, really? I'm kidding.
谢谢。是的。谢谢，肖恩。是的。就是这样。我要第一次尝试毒品。噢，真的吗？开玩笑的。
I'm kidding. You've never tried drugs, right, Sean? Me? No, I got, I would get stoned all the time, I'm kidding. You've never tried drugs, right Sean? Me, no, I got, I would get stoned all the time, smoke pot constantly. And now I take gummies, which is nice. But the only hard thing I tried was- Well, they're legal nowadays, right? Yeah, they're legal, they're legal.
开玩笑的。你从来没试过毒品，对吧，肖恩？我？没有，我，我一直都很嗨，开玩笑的。你从来没试过毒品，对吧，肖恩？我，没有，我，我一直都很嗨，一直抽大麻。现在我吃软糖，这很好。但我尝试过的唯一硬东西是——好吧，它们现在合法了，对吧？是的，它们合法了，它们合法了。
But I tried mushrooms once and it was just insane. I felt like I weighed 250 pounds and it was just awful. Awful. It was terrible. 250 pound mushroom, a film coming to you soon. Yeah, it was terrible. You wish. Yeah, that was awful.
但我试过一次蘑菇，简直疯了。我觉得我重了250磅，简直太糟糕了。糟糕。太可怕了。250磅的蘑菇，一部电影即将上映。是的，太可怕了。你想得美。是的，那太糟糕了。
Yeah, that's it. Wow, and then what's that process like? So now you're done, you've completed the record and it's gonna come out and you're not gonna tour, maybe you'll do a few dates, a few live dates or a show here or there. And then I guess it's not unlike for us working on a film and then you kind of go and you move on
是的，就是这样。哇，那过程是什么样的？所以现在你完成了，你完成了唱片，它要发行了，你不会巡演，也许你会做几个日期，几个现场日期或在这里或那里的演出。然后我想这和我们制作电影没什么不同，然后你有点走开，继续前进，
and then it's like, it's hard to say goodbye, I'm sure, when you make a connection. I mean, you're still friends, obviously, but- To that project, you mean. When you do something that's so intensely creative. We talk every day and we see each other every chance we get. We'll always be making music together as long as we can. Wow, that's fantastic.
然后就像，很难说再见，我相信，当你建立联系时。我的意思是，你们显然还是朋友，但是——你是说那个项目。当你做一些如此强烈创造性的事情时。我们每天都交谈，只要有机会就见面。只要我们能，我们就会一直在一起创作音乐。哇，那太棒了。
Yeah, I love that. I ain't letting go of it. What? What's that? He said he ain't letting go. No. That's good, that's good. Well, we can't thank you both enough for joining us
是的，我喜欢那样。我不会放手的。什么？什么？他说他不会放手。不。那很好，那很好。好吧，我们非常感谢你们俩加入我们，
upon this and talking to us about your album. We really appreciate it. Thank you guys. Yeah, it's been a pleasure. We can't thank you both enough for joining us on this and talking to us about your album. We really, really appreciate it. Yeah, it's been a pleasure. It's been an honor. Thanks, fellas. Good to see you both. Continued success to you both,
谈论你们的专辑。我们真的很感激。谢谢你们。是的，这是一种荣幸。我们非常感谢你们俩加入我们，谈论你们的专辑。我们真的，真的很感激。是的，这是一种荣幸。这是一种荣幸。谢谢，伙计们。很高兴见到你们俩。祝你们俩继续成功，
and specifically with this album. We're really rooting for your careers. Please think of something to do with that. Think of something to do with that footage. Please put it together so we can all get that privileged view into the process. Oh well, I hope we meet each other soon so we can give each other a big hug and Sean.
特别是这张专辑。我们真的在为你们的职业生涯加油。请想办法处理那些素材。想办法处理那些素材。请把它整理出来，这样我们所有人都能获得那种特权，一窥创作过程。噢，好吧，我希望我们很快能见面，这样我们就能给彼此一个大大的拥抱，肖恩。
I do miss you, I love you very much, okay? I miss you too, honey, I love you too. Thanks, it's good to see you. Thanks you guys so much. Enjoy the rest of your day. Bye. Bye. Bye. Jason, how in the world, I mean, did you, how did you quote, land them?
我确实想你，我非常爱你，好吗？我也想你，亲爱的，我也爱你。谢谢，很高兴见到你。非常感谢你们。享受你们剩下的一天。再见。再见。再见。杰森，到底是怎么，我的意思是，你，你是怎么，引用，搞定他们的？
That's, I'm reminded of the same question I asked you after we had Sir Paul McCartney on the show. How did you land, and you said it was an incoming. This is an incoming. Oh wow. Wow, wait. That's amazing. Yeah, they're promoting that album
那是，我想起了保罗·麦卡特尼爵士上节目后我问你的同一个问题。你是怎么搞定他们的，你说这是一个主动联系。这是一个主动联系。噢，哇。哇，等等。太神奇了。是的，他们正在宣传那张专辑，
and I guess they're doing a podcast and we were chosen, I suppose. I don't know, I didn't question, I just said that there was a question as to, are we, how do we feel about doing a double guess? Which we've done a couple of times, but it's been rare. It's been musicians, it's been musicians. It was Billie Eilish and her brother Fidious. Yeah, yeah.
我想他们正在做播客，我想我们被选中了。我不知道，我没有质疑，我只是说有一个问题，我们，我们对做双人嘉宾感觉如何？我们做过几次，但很少见。是音乐家，是音乐家。是比莉·艾利什和她的兄弟菲迪亚斯。是的，是的。
And the Smile guys, Radiohead guys. Radiohead, and then. Johnny and Tom York. And then Arcade. Arcade Fire, Arcade Fire as well. And then, right. Yeah, it is odd that it has been. Depeche Mode.
还有Smile乐队的人，Radiohead的人。Radiohead，然后。约翰尼和汤姆·约克。然后Arcade。Arcade Fire，Arcade Fire也是。然后，对。是的，确实很奇怪。Depeche Mode。
It's just been music, yeah. But yeah, it was really kind of just no doubt about it. Double barrel shotgun on those two. Yeah, I mean, sure, that's just incredible. I mean, I know I said it already, but it's like, I mean, both of those guys have, go ahead. Well, I just, Sean, I'm looking at your face, and first of all, you know,
只是音乐，是的。但确实，毫无疑问。双管齐下搞定那两个。是的，我的意思是，当然，那简直不可思议。我的意思是，我知道我已经说过了，但就像，我的意思是，他们两个都有，继续。好吧，我只是，肖恩，我看着你的脸，首先，你知道，
that Elton John knows where you live. And that he's been to your house, and that he's played on your piano. But I just want to, and you mention all the time Glen Ellyn, Illinois, to the point that we're all so sick of it, but did you, is there, is there, for you the novelty, as a kid growing up in Glen Ellyn, Illinois, who loved music,
埃尔顿·约翰知道你住哪里。他去过你家，他在你的钢琴上弹奏过。但我只是想，而且你一直提到伊利诺伊州格伦埃林，以至于我们都听腻了，但你，有没有，有没有，对你来说，作为在伊利诺伊州格伦埃林长大的孩子，热爱音乐，
who's sitting there with four siblings, no dad, is there part of you that- Wait, go back, go back, go back, go back, what? Yeah, what's that? Yeah, siblings, no dad, is there part of you that would- Wait, go back, go back, go back, go back, what? No, what's that? Yeah, no, he's gone. I'm just trying to paint a picture. But it must be for you, Sean, it must be mind blowing that you're talking to Elton John.
坐在那里有四个兄弟姐妹，没有父亲，有没有一部分你——等等，回去，回去，回去，回去，什么？是的，那是什么？是的，兄弟姐妹，没有父亲，有没有一部分你——等等，回去，回去，回去，回去，什么？不，那是什么？是的，不，他走了。我只是想描绘一幅画面。但对你来说，肖恩，你正在和埃尔顿·约翰交谈，这一定让你大开眼界。
Yeah, it always is, and you know- Your buddy. Your buddy, yeah. You kind of suppress it because you can't believe it, so you kind of stuff it down. I believe the sign off was, buy honey is what you call them. You said buy honey.
是的，总是这样，而且你知道——你的伙伴。你的伙伴，是的。你有点压抑它，因为你不敢相信，所以你把它压下去了。我相信告别语是，买亲爱的，这是你称呼他们的。你说买亲爱的。
That's sir Elton John, and he went with honey. You know where he gets that, you know where he developed that from? It's from Jimmy Burroughs. You know Burroughs calls everybody honey. Honey, one more time. You're like, I'll do the scene again. Stop calling me honey in front of the crew.
那是埃尔顿·约翰爵士，他用了亲爱的。你知道他从哪里得到的吗，你知道他从哪里发展出这个习惯的吗？是从吉米·伯勒斯那里。你知道伯勒斯称呼每个人为亲爱的。亲爱的，再来一次。你就像，我会再做一次场景。别在剧组面前叫我亲爱的。
Yeah, it's such a habit now. Everybody from Will and Grace calls everybody honey. But yeah the crew. Yeah, it's such a habit now. I know. Everybody from Will and Grace calls everybody honey. But yeah, no, he, yes, exactly. Well, thank you for saying that. Yeah, but when people would come on Will and Grace or I would like, Elton John was on Will and Grace or whatever it was, or whoever I meet in this business,
是的，现在这成了一种习惯。《威尔和格蕾丝》里的每个人都称呼每个人为亲爱的。但是的，剧组。是的，现在这成了一种习惯。我知道。《威尔和格蕾丝》里的每个人都称呼每个人为亲爱的。但是的，不，他，是的，没错。好吧，谢谢你这么说。是的，但当人们来到《威尔和格蕾丝》或者我，埃尔顿·约翰在《威尔和格蕾丝》上，或者无论是什么，或者我在这个行业里遇到谁，
I just filled with, always filled with gratitude when you wake up. That's where it all starts from. And if you're there, then everybody's on the same playing field, right? Everybody you as much that's me trying to suppress like oh my god it's yeah you know but you're like wow it's yeah anyway it's my long answer what's a thrill to play like I know JB's playing golf with with Thomas Rhett today like I know his whole schedule you know like am I right you are right you
我总是充满感激，当你醒来时。这就是一切开始的地方。如果你在那里，那么每个人都在同一个起跑线上，对吧？每个人你就像那是我想压抑像噢天哪它是是的你知道但你就像哇它是是的无论如何这是我的长回答，演奏真是太刺激了，就像我知道JB今天和托马斯·瑞特打高尔夫球一样，我知道他的整个日程，你知道，我说的对吗，你是对的，你
are right he you are right. He texted me during the show, he's such a great guy, and he said, hey man, I wish you were playing today, because obviously you're not enough, and so, which is, but I mean, honestly, even JB, you're not even a musician, you don't even know what music is, for you Elton John and Brandy must be a thrill. Tell us about that.
是对的。他在节目期间给我发短信，他真是个好人，他说，嘿伙计，我希望你今天能来玩，因为显然你还不够，所以，这，但我的意思是，老实说，即使是JB，你甚至不是音乐家，你甚至不知道什么是音乐，对你来说埃尔顿·约翰和布兰迪一定很刺激。告诉我们那个。
I have to admit, I think I was more nervous for that than I can, I think I've probably been more nervous for some of these, but I can't remember which one. I don't remember, it's been a while. Like I've got tons and tons and tons of questions here, and I couldn't bring myself to ask any of them, of either one of them. I just didn't know where to start,
我必须承认，我想我对此比我能，我想我可能对其中一些更紧张，但我记不起是哪一个了。我不记得了，已经有一段时间了。就像我这里有成吨成吨的问题，我无法让自己问他们中的任何一个。我只是不知道从哪里开始，
what the hell to say. Right, because you want to do the Chris Farley thing where he interviews famous people, he's like, you know, when he did Paul McCartney. Remember when you were in The Beatles? But I mean, with both of them too, with Brandy, it's just like, I'm just not sure what to say to people like that.
该死地说什么。对，因为你想做克里斯·法利那样采访名人的事情，就像，你知道，当他采访保罗·麦卡特尼时。记得你在披头士乐队的时候吗？但我的意思是，对他们两个也是，对布兰迪，我只是不知道对那样的人说什么。
I wanted to ask him about every song, and like, how did you think of it, and where did it come from? And you just know he's so over it. Well, thank God you waited until he was gone again. Well, but I wanted to be respectful of Brandy. I didn't want to just make it all about him. I wanted to like make it about the album.
我想问他关于每一首歌，就像，你是怎么想到的，它来自哪里？你只是知道他已经听腻了。好吧，感谢上帝，你等到他再次离开。好吧，但我想要尊重布兰迪。我不想只谈论他。我想谈论这张专辑。
Brandy gets it too. I mean, she's such an accomplished singer, songwriter. She's amazing. Honestly, that tribute for Jimmy Buffett last year, she was on, she brought the house down. She was unbelievable. Yeah, she was stunning. And the house down. She was unbelievable. Yeah, she was stunning. And Give Up the Ghost really is a great album.
布兰迪也懂。我的意思是，她是一位非常有成就的歌手、词曲作者。她太棒了。老实说，去年吉米·巴菲特的那个致敬演出，她在上面，她让全场沸腾。她令人难以置信。是的，她太惊艳了。让全场沸腾。她令人难以置信。是的，她太惊艳了。《Give Up the Ghost》确实是一张很棒的专辑。
I love that. Anyway. Yeah, she's got incredible presence. I had no idea though that they were such close friends and that they vacationed together. For 20 years they've been buddies. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, you know what, listen,
我喜欢那样。无论如何。是的，她有令人难以置信的魅力。不过我不知道他们是这么亲密的朋友，而且他们一起度假。他们当朋友20年了。是的，是的，是的。是的，你知道吗，听着，
I think there's only one thing that I can say. Having them here today. Yeah? Having them today. And I just want to say, you know, it's nice to say, it's nice to say hello to some new friends. Oh no, that's terrible. But it's also nice to say,
我想我只能说一件事。今天让他们在这里。是的？今天让他们在这里。我只想说，你知道，很高兴向一些新朋友问好。噢不，那太糟糕了。但也很高兴说，
goodbye, Yellow Brick Road. Bye. That's the one I was going to use too. Smart. Less. Smart. gonna use too. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见，黄砖路。再见。那也是我打算用的那个。聪明。少。聪明。打算用的那个。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。